I appreciate that I appreciate you being
in a good mood it was a difficult week
very depressing week I'm sure you saw
Hamas the terrorist group that runs GA
Gaza um broken Israel killed over 1300
people men women and children and then
the college kids in America went full
Trump and said there's very fine people
on both
sides what is going on 34 Harvard
Association Student Association signed a
letter that basically threw their lot in
with the Killers uh but there was a
backlash because some CEOs said when
these kids now go for a job they're
going to be blacklisted
and and a lot of the students are still
standing by their position to support
the war criminals but they strenuously
object to the word
Blacklist
even Kanye said that is some
anti-semitic
right
uh and then there's the Democratic
socialists of America I didn't really
wasn't aware of these people but they
exist and I I'm not sure I'm with with
them uh the Connecticut chapter uh put
out a statement they said no peace on
Stolen land uh this is from
Connecticut an Indian word that means
that land you stole so you know and by
the way it's not stolen land okay not
stolen land uh so yes and then I I heard
about this other person I was not aware
of before porn star Mia Khalifa uh also
rejoiced in The Killing uh she said said
they should turn their phones horizontal
so she could see the Carnage in in 4k uh
proving that you literally can have your
brains
out
man where is Donald Trump when you need
someone to pay a porn star to shut the
up
yes I'm I'm learning about Mia Khalifa
she apparently is famous for giving a
and a HUD
job I'm not kidding really did that I I
I wonder if you know this Mia that if
you tried to practice your trade in Gaza
I'm not sure they would give you a warm
welcome uh no they would because you'd
be on fire you
nitwit
but of
course now everyone in Israel is asking
how did this devastating breach of
security even happened why did Israeli
intelligence not get an idea that this
was coming why did American intelligence
not know this and Marjorie Taylor green
said where were the space
lasers